>> THIS IS BAD WHEN YOU'VE GOT
LASERS.
>> YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO POINT.
>> HOW'S IT GOING TO WORK,
CHUCK.
>> YOU DON'T HAVE TO GET UP,
FOOL.
YOU HAVE A LASER.
THAT'S THE POINT OF A LASER.
>> GETTING IN FRONT OF THAT.
RUIN THE SHOT.
BUT GO AHEAD.
>> AMERICA, OKAY.
LOSER, LOSER.
>> HERE'S WHAT'S GOING HAPPEN.
>> YOU'RE NOT EXPLAINING.
>> HERE'S WHAT HAPPENS.
THESE ARE LOSERS.
THESE TWO ARE GOING PLAY EACH
OTHER.
THE HALF LOSERS ARE GOING THE TO
THE PLAY.
THE TWO TOP LOSERS MOVE OVER
HERE.
>> THEY'RE NOT THE TOP LOSERS.
THEY'RE 9 AND 10.
>> 9 IS PLAYING 10.
>> YEAH, THE TWO LOSERS.
THEY PLAY EACH OTHER AND THE
WINNER GETS MOVED OVER HERE.
>> THEN WHAT HAPPENS?
>> THE BABY LOSERS, SEVEN AND
EIGHT PLAY OVER HERE.
>> WHERE DOES THE WINNER GO?
>> TO SEVEN SEED OVER HERE AND
THESE TWO LOSERS ARE GOING PLAY
THE NUMBER ONE SEED AND WILL BE
LOSERED OUT AFTER THE FIRST
ROUND OF THE PLAYOFFS.
>> I HAVE A FEELING IT'S GOING
BE THE SAME THING IN THE OTHER
SIDE.
>> THESE ARE TWO LOSERS.
THESE ARE NINE AND TEN.
>> IF NINE BEATS TEN, WHAT
HAPPENS?
>> THEY PLAY THE LOSER OF
SEVEN/EIGHT.
THEY PLAY THE SECOND LOSER.
>> OKAY.
>> AND THEN THE WINNER PLAYS THE
EIGHTH SEED, THE FIRST LOSER.
THEY'RE GOING GET KILLED.
THEN THE SECOND LOSER GOES DOWN
HERE THE SEVENTH SEED.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT THIS SOUNDS
LIKE?
SOMEBODY EXPLAINING CRYPTO COINS
TO ME.
I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT THEY WE